I'm Dave Ruben this is the Ruben
reporter we've got another Friday
Roundtable Extravaganza for you joining
me our two firsttime guests on the ruin
report first up comedian and musician
Ami kazac and Israeli political
commentator mayor cand ammy Maya welcome
to the Reuben report thank you
Dave uh I should say Ami this is your
first appearance on the Ruben report as
a Live guest although you did make a
mini appearance about a week oh it was a
week ago today actually uh because you
were on that video with Candace Owens
talking about the Muslim quarter and you
guys got into a little bit do you want
to give me like a 30 second recap of
that thing and then we'll uh we'll talk
to Mayor and get into all the topics
sure um you know I really approached my
conversation with Candace Owens as a
conversation I wasn't wasn't there to
try to win in some sort of debate I've
learned from people like The Joe Rogan
of the world and the Jordan Petersons of
the world to really listen to people
when you engage with them and to try to
take everything in good faith to her
credit I tweeted her that morning and
within a few hours she invited me on to
have the conversation and it became
pretty clear within our conversation
that she really was very unaware about a
lot of the things regarding Israel and
the history of Israel the current state
of Israel and it was revealed in that
moment that um there was something that
confused her about it and I took that as
an opportunity to just shed some light
on it and I was very gracious I think in
when she described that she saw the
Muslim quarters and the Jewish quarters
and had a misunderstanding over how
Muslims and Jews and Christians and
other groups coexisted in the old city
of Jerusalem and so yeah I felt you know
compelled to correct that and then when
she tried to draw the connections to
segregation in this country I think it
was a I took the approach of from a
conservative standpoint from a
conservative perspective you know when
you look at a surface understanding of
something like if you go into an inin
neighborhood or a black neighborhood in
this country would you then all of a
sudden assume systemic racism in the
United States by just drawing a strange
conclusion from a surface understanding
and I think maybe shouldn't expect me to
make that case from that perspective but
I do think hopefully the conversation
between us was cordial and constructive
and can help move the needle in a
certain way because ignorance is is
easier to fix than hate you know and I
think it's important to try to make
those distinctions even though emotions
run high and these are difficult
subjects for someone not to be aware of
something or ignorant about something we
all are I've said a lot of things that I
you know didn't really you know in we
all kind of guilty that in some respects
so ignorance is easier to fix and combat
than than hate yeah well I'm glad to
hear you say that and of course that's a
uh a premise that I go with here when
I'm doing this show and yes it was not
I'm not I'm not bringing it up again to
own her other than it to show that we
can all sometimes not know exactly what
we're talking about and it's good when
people can fill in the blanks Maya uh
you although you've never been on the
Reuben report you are an integral
integral piece of the Reuben report
because when we went to Israel uh you
live in Jerusalem although I think
you're in London at the moment and you
were our trusty Torah guide and your
family had my entire team over uh for
Shabbat dinner in Jerusalem which was an
absolutely wonderful day and you you
showed us around the country and took us
all over the place so I guess mostly
just thanking you but is there anything
else you want to say about yourself
before we dive in um I'm pretty I just
feel like I'm doing my pot to try and
share an actually accurate perspective
not just on the news but also on
analysis in a way that isn't going to uh
traumatize people everywhere so that's
kind of what I do it's not so super
exciting but I'm glad to be here and
happy to share my perspective on some
stuff on that note we will try not to
traumatize people for the next half hour
so first let me get to an ad and then
we'll see if we can make that work uh
guys I want to share something truly
exciting picture this an investment
opportunity that's been quietly
generating substantial income outside
the chaos of the stock market this isn't
your typical stock Bond or option it's
something bigger something that's been
delivering incredible returns we're
stepping into an unprecedented energy
bull market akin to the booming 70s
where the demand for oil is skyrocketing
predictions are in brace yourself for
much higher oil prices Global demand is
set to hit a staggering 100 1 million
barrels per day driving prices and
royalties to new heights but here's the
game changer oil and gas royalties
picture collecting income without the
roller coaster ride of drilling
exploration costs or workforce
management you just sit back and reap
the rewards from oil sales now the
golden opportunity we're talking about a
peran basin royalty stream the crown
jewel of oil reserves Warren buffets
wagered a cool 12 billion on this region
and listen to this while stocks bonds
and crypto stumbled this royalty stream
sword with a staggering 149% returns in
2022 alone quarter Revenue growth
boasting an astounding
77% and over 42 million in rev over the
past year consistency is key right while
this Royal stream has been serving up
monthly dividends and payments without
fail since 2 276 consecutive months of
steady income so listeners imagine being
part of this success story don't let
this opportunity slip and step into an
investment that's proven lucrative and
ready to fuel your financial future go
to 2024 oil boo.com or click the link
below and get started today okay guys
let's dive right into it obviously
there's no shortage of things to talk
about this week we're mostly going to
talk about of course the Fallout from uh
October 7th in Israel and the reaction
kind of around the world uh one of the
most disappointing things is that uh we
have several members of the Democrat
what I call Hamas caucus here in the
United States who are standing firmly
with Hamas uh well here here's ilhan
Omar
something fascinating and
bizarre um in the fact that there are
people who seem to be upset that there
are rabbis and people other people of
Faith out here asking for
ceasefire and it's it's bizarre because
you would
assume that if you are a religious
leader if you are a faith
leader that your number one
priority would be to look into your
faith into the teachings of your faith
and to say I oppose
violence all right I'll first off speak
for myself not for you guys she's
absolutely vile and a Hamas apologist
also I don't know that these are actual
rabbis standing behind her and for a
bunch of people that talk about cultural
appropriation all the time the idea that
she would speak for any religious person
outside of her religion is slightly
ironic but Maya you were in Israel
during uh October 7th um you are a
religious person yourself and come from
a religious family your father is an
actual Rabbi uh could you talk a little
bit about her
commentary well I have a lot of things
to say about her bizarre commentary but
I guess we'll start with the fact that
as somebody who studied um Judaism in
depth for the last 25 years of my life I
can tell
for a fact that we believe whil we do
believe in peace we also truly and
totally believe in as a commandment in
the ability to defend ourselves against
any enemy that comes to kill us if
you're if you're someone's coming to
kill you you kill them first and that's
the basis of I don't want say the base
of our religion but it's a pretty clear
and well-known fact so the lack of
education is just totally and completely
obvious um and yeah I I researched this
group there's about 40 of them so to go
ahead and pretend like the rabbis of the
world are out there you know cooling for
a ceasefire which is really a different
way of saying um allowing Kamas to kill
more Israelis is just it's just bizarre
and it's stupid Amy helped me with this
one because the same people who are
calling for The River To The Sea are
calling for a ceasefire now I'm I'm no
genius but something doesn't add up here
I always find it very curious when ill
Omar and members of the squad are
incredibly imprecise when condemning
violence against Jews and Israelis but
incredibly precise the other way around
you know remember some people did
something somewhere
sometime you know this is this is what
is happening there and this and but now
when it comes to condemning Israel very
precise language that's very curious to
me but what's really uh you
know confusing and it's it's not
shocking if you really examine it
politically and ideologically is that
um I don't understand why a lot of these
people who claim to be morally virtuous
and signal that uh virtue are not
calling for the unconditional surrender
of Kamas and return of the hostages that
would certainly end this immediate
campaign that's going on caring about
all the human life that's been lost let
us remember every single person who is
no longer with us who has been killed in
this war was alive on October 4th 5th
and 6th Israeli and Palestinian and
quite short memory you have ilhan Omar
to say this needs to stop this idea of
ceasefire this idea for and call for
pacifism is highly immoral in the face
of aggression you have a choice as a
community and as a state and as a people
in Israel and around the world between
self-defense and suicide and a lot of
these people claiming I think maybe for
some people psychologically the idea of
pacifism and ceasefire sounds good but
what you're really saying is that in the
face of aggression you just need to
accept it and take it uh the real thing
that would stop this is the return of
the hostages and the unconditional
surrender of Kamas I don't and that
would be beneficial to innocent
Palestinians and obviously Israel but
none of these people uh are calling for
that which begs the question is this
about creating a free Palestinian state
or about eliminating a Jewish State and
you yeah to that exact point AOC
followed up at that very same rally and
she seems to think there is no military
solution which is why she wants a
ceasefire although I suspect if Israel
was losing right now she would not be
calling for a ceasefire I don't think it
takes a rocket science a rocket
scientist to figure that out take a look
ceasefire means there is no military
solution only a diplomatic and cultural
solution a relational solution a
Reckoning with ourselves in our history
that is what ceasefire now means I mean
it's just pure driil I'm sorry I have no
other way to describe it there's no
military solution well first off we know
that there is the destruction of Hamas
the return of the hostages and and
borders that are clean that if they're
you know ransacked over obviously you're
going to do what you got to do but she
thinks there's a diplomatic and cultural
solution uh mayor as someone that lives
in Israel can you talk about not only
how no Israelis live in Gaza and haven't
lived in Gaza since 2005 but I haven't
heard one Israeli since well maybe in
the last three weeks been like we got to
send some Israelis there but nobody
wants anything to do with the place but
there should be a diplomatic and
cultural answer well I think this is
just a very clear example of when
somebody from the West thinks that they
understand something to to no ends even
though they have no real skin in the
game I mean it's very very clear
diplomacy is simple it's the
conversation that leads leads to peace
right you have to have two people on the
table who are interested in getting to a
peaceful solution Kamas are clear that
they're not interested in that and
they're also clear they're not
interested in conversation if you look
at the hostage situation you'll see they
have no interest in talking to us so
somebody coming and spouting idiocy
basically saying something along the
lines of oh let's just have a
conversation about it is obviously so
unaware of the realities of the
situation and to claim that there's no
military solution there is a very simple
military solution the eradication of
Kamas exactly as the IDF is doing right
now and the fact that you stand up there
and say such things to an audience is
again shocking but we know that Amy
there was a military solution to the
Nazis wasn't
there yeah this is what moral confusion
looks like remember her rant in Congress
um AOC is like you know I I think that
it it runs very deep it's it's this idea
that perhaps on the very far left when
faced with evil you know there's this
temptation to externalize it and this
this happens across the board no actors
are actually involved here there are no
aggressors there's no behavior on
hamas's part that's accountable for this
um and therefore to do that all of a
sudden war and conflict just come upon
Humanity like some some force that we
can't control it's like no no no no no
if you want peace if you want peace you
need to eliminate those who don't share
your value for peace who don't desire
peace it's wonderful to say the solution
to war is peace but that is a
meaningless expression when you have
actors and regimes involved committed to
the destruction of one per people and
acted out so yeah we want peace how do
you get peace you will eliminate and
fight those people who are violently
opposed to it and this just displays
such a you know a moral confusion when
look when when faced with evil and a
historical ignorance of the five times
Israel has offered Palestinian statehood
and met with further violence and
aggression and maybe even the last 17 to
20 oh nearly 20 years of Israel leaving
Gaza as an experiment and look what
happens so you know I just if she if she
really thought it through or you know
the real case to be made is if you want
to fight for a pre free Palestinian
State you need to eliminate those who
stand in the way of it which is clearly
Kamas they they don't talk about you
know creating a two-state solution and
talk about diplomacy they talk about
committing genocide against Jews
worldwide and eliminating the state of
Israel and now we're seeing it
unapologetically on the streets pramas
rallies not pro two-state Solutions and
then she has theah to talk about
ceasefires and peace and without that
recognition it's hard to believe it's
not willful but that's what we're seeing
I'm mean you're really killing it with
the that's pretty good May right's I'm
Orthodox too I'm orthodox there you go
I'm holding I'm holding you know well I
would say the the tragedy within the
tragedy brings us to the next video
today because the international response
has been bizarre at best I mean at the
moment Israel is doing what it's got to
do and it has uh some uh International
backing behind it uh but Justin Trudeau
who who literally was was closing
people's bank accounts who were
protesting against him in Canada who is
no moral Arbiter of anything uh here's
what he had to say just a few days ago
about Israel's action in
Gaza the human tragedy that is unfolding
in Gaza is heart-wrenching especially
the suffering we see in and around the
alifa hospital I have been clear that
the price of Justice cannot be the
continued suffering of all Palestinian
civilians even Wars have
rules all innocent life is equal in
worth Israeli and
Palestinian I urge the government of
Israel to
exercise maximum
restraint as the world is
watching on TV on social media we're
hearing the testimonies of doctors
family members
survivors kids who've lost their parents
the world world is witnessing this the
killing of women and
children of
babies this has to
stop he is gener he is evil I don't know
how to put it in other way he he is evil
who the hell does he think he is that he
can tell another Western democracy how
they should defend their men women and
children mayor can you talk a little bit
about the things that Israel actually
has done like dropping leaflets and
things of that nature and the things
that Hamas has done to maximize uh
civilian casualties maybe that'll
Enlighten Justin Trudeau just a little
bit I mean if you would like me to talk
about it we're never going to end this
show but I think I think there's
something that's this is this is
actually a scary Trend to talk about
because I think we're going to see more
and more of this people who came out at
the beginning being all like oh we
support Israel support Israel but then
the the issue with this is really the
fact that he is is putting the
responsibility on Israel I mean netan
responded to this tweet but I to not
we'll get to that in a moment but I
think that I think that Israel has gone
above and beyond um you know the truth
is Israel could have completely blitzed
and Blom bombed all of Gaza in the first
three days and we would have this whole
thing would have been over we have the
military capacity and yet you could say
it's because of the hostages but I don't
think that's true I think it's also true
I think it's to do with the fact we
actually value human human life and
Kamas does not and that is basis of all
actions and the fact that there are
people in the west who still are not
capable of understanding that the
responsibility for every single civilian
casualty in this entire war from
beginning to end lives with one group
and one group only and that is Kamas to
point the fingers on Israel and to say
to them to hold to have restraint it's
not just idiotic it's pathetic and I
think you need to ask yourself as a
leader of a country what would you do
what would you do like really you you
would hold restraint more to the fact I
don't see somebody like Justin and
Trudeau ask like putting his skin in the
game and offering for the gazin to come
live in Canada no they're just happy to
sit and watch by and say this is what
Israel is doing wrong and this is how
Israel should act they hav't he hasn't
visited he hasn't seen and he just he's
a populist and he drives me
insane I me I don't think I have to ask
you a question just talk about Justin
Trudeau sure sure I think I know how to
get him on Israel's side all we have to
do is tell him that Kamas is not
vaccinated exactly Simple Solution he
would turn against them in a second um
you know and not to throw another
impression into it but I heard Jordan
Pederson described Justin Trudeau as
pure Persona you
know and and it didn't he's pure Persona
you know it's like well um the balls in
your yeah in your court he it didn't
take very long for the lip service of
being a Western pro-israel Country
allied with Israel to completely fall on
its face the condemnation by which and
the tone of his condemnation speaking
towards Israel I think is very
consistent with what we've seen from
Trudeau and especially those you know in
the far-left sort of w culture that we
find ourselves in in on the political
side to the extent that a country is
virtuous and good in the eyes of someone
like Trudeau Trudeau they are bad they
are accountable they are responsible not
they they are responsible for putting
the lives and citizens of the enemy
combatants who've attacked them above
the security of their own and this is
just a pure perversion of morality and
Justice to Signal some kind of virtue
that um it is more virtuous for the
prosperous strong Nation to be
villainized and looked at as the ones
responsible the ones who are successful
have only become successful at the
exploitation of others it's very
consistent ideologically with everything
else he believes about whatever you want
to say when it comes to the ideas of
stuff on the far left this this this
affects the way they think about world
affairs and foreign affairs in War I
like Israel's responsibility as a
government is to the security of its
citizens and to protect its citizens and
it goes the extra mile to Showcase its
value for human life and why is not
justtin Trudeau condemning Kamas who is
unapologetically devaluing human life
where is that condemnation where is that
call for returning the hostages where is
that call for their surrender where is
the call for condemning Kamas for
embedding themselves in the civilian
population it's not there because I
think jvo views the uh the country that
has the higher standard of living that
has the more moral High Ground as
inherently bad this is the inversion
that he views the world in I would say
there's another piece of this which is
that he fears the islamists on his
streets and he doesn't fear the Jews and
that that's actually probably what's
happening all across Western Europe
beyond Canada it's what's happening in
London and it's probably what's
happening in France they don't fear well
the Jews the Jews are going to burn down
the whole place no they're not but they
feel that the other guys are going to
burn down by the way this other line
that he said when you talk about the
ideology connected to this war has rules
well I suppose in some theoretical thing
that that's kind of true to a certain
extent that is why Israel sends out
leaflets and makes calls and texts
people no other army in the world has
ever done this although I think maybe
maybe the US Army did it a little bit in
Iraq uh but uh mayor I'm sure pretty
sure Hamas they don't have rules when it
comes to this stuff right no you know we
actually have a what there's a WhatsApp
group in Israel presented by the IDF for
gazin to contact if they are finding
that Hamas is putting them in a
uncomfortable situation by uncomfortable
situation I mean not threatening them
and threatening to kill them if they try
and leave right Israel is actively
actively involved in providing so much
humanitarian care to the gazin I mean to
a point where some I think a lot of
Israelis would question why why why we
need to go that way why we need to go
that route they there's I don't think
there's a strong feeling that the gazin
deserve it and I think I think we do it
because we believe in human life and we
believe in sanctifying that and we
genuinely genuinely care the fact that
the world has managed to twist it is
unbelievable but Kamas Have No
Boundaries they have no boundaries and
that but comes from a completely
different perspective of looking at life
I think as a western it's a hard thing
to understand grasp the concept of
somebody genuinely believing that
killing a baby and getting support for
that is better than a baby Staying Alive
we don't we can't wrap our head around
that but they believe that and that's
the way they act and if you're if you're
somebody who's continuing to tried to
understand this conflict from the
Western perspective and isn't doing
anything to try and understand maybe
what a terrorist organization might be
thinking you're not going to understand
this conflict whatsoever yeah that's a
great point I want to read BB's response
to uh Justin Trudeau he tweeted this out
he said it is not Israel that is
deliberately targeting civilians but
Hamas that beheaded burned and massacred
civilians in the worst Horrors
perpetrated on Jews since the Holocaust
while Israel is doing everything to keep
civilians out of Harm's Way Hamas is
doing everything to keep them in In
Harm's Way Israel provides civilians in
Gaza humanitarian corridors and safe
zones Hamas prevents them from leaving
at gunpoint it is Hamas not Israel that
should be held accountable for
committing a double War crime targeting
civilians while hiding behind civilians
the forces of civilization must back
Israel in defeating Hamas barbarism uh
Amy before we jump on to the final topic
do you think that there's also an
inherent asymmetry in that Israel is the
only country that's ever were asked to
explain themselves and perhaps if one
day they just decided not to explain
themselves anymore like everybody else
that it actually might behoove them in a
weird
way yeah I know I find that Israel in a
way is in this abusive relationship with
the Western world that condemns them and
to the extent that they cave to it and
enable it and try to Showcase that
they're better in that sense they only
get further punished for it so yes I
think it's reached this point where
after multiple attempts to to pleas the
Western mob that condemns them and holds
them to an impossible standard BB should
just get get up there and
say this is what we're going to do like
forget it like we have to do what we
have to do to defend ourselves and we
cannot fight to defend ourselves while
at the same time convincing the rest of
the world that we're justified in doing
so if you wake up on October 8th after
October 7th and cannot see the
civilizational difference here uh the
moral difference here between Israel and
its enemies then your moral compass is
broken Bren and it's on you to fix it
and maybe one day we'll be able to
engage in that conversation but in the
meantime we're at War we know we have
the moral High Ground And if you know
and watching all the abundance of
footage and evidence of what Kamas did
on October 7th and celebrating it and to
see people not celebrating Holocaust
perpet being perpetuated Holocaust uh
celebration and Holocaust Denial in real
time all of these reality collapses
going on you guys go think what you
think judge how you want it's not going
to make a difference either way we we we
have to defend ourselves as an Israel
tell you that there was a lot of anger
at this tweet because people are just
fed up we do not need to justify
anything we're going to look inside why
is why is Nan wasting any time on
responding to somebody who obviously
does not have his our best intentions
it's it's enough is enough we don't have
to justify anything we're doing what's
right we're moving forward and the
Western World can either get in line
with that or they
can
bleep we dropped a lot of f bombss on
the show this week so I appreciate you
uh going going easy on me on that one
well let's shift this to the mainstream
media because Amy it's going to make
your exact point about constantly trying
to rationalize yourself to people who
will blame you for everything um there
the the deputy mayor of Jerusalem her
name is FL Hassan Nahum uh I interviewed
her in Jerusalem I was blown away by
this woman her energy her passion her
love for the city of Jerusalem was just
absolutely incredible uh she was on
Andrea Mitchell's show on the televised
mental tion known as MSNBC and Andrea
Mitchell who is a Jew and a homas
apologist here she is blaming Israel for
the rise of anti-Semitism you know
Europe is on fire with anti-israel
protests and messaging the US now we see
this counter march today which is trying
to balance it out but there were
problems all all across the us as well
in anti-semitic incidents is there a
better way for Israel to process this
war something that the US has been
urging quietly and now publicly in terms
of using smart bombs not dumb bombs
small ammunitions landrea you know this
is a war we didn't ask for we didn't
provoke we didn't start it was something
we never expected uh to have 2,500
terrorists come in and you saw it
yourself hours of torture innocent
babies who were decapitated women whose
pregnant women whose stomachs were open
babies taken out you know how horrific
that was I don't know of any country
that wouldn't want to go and defend its
citizens from essentially an existential
threat and not just that the leaders of
Kamas are saying we're going to do
October the 7th again and again and
again so Israel has been put in an
impossible situation now Israel Has the
strength to flatten Gaza but we're not
doing it we're putting our soldiers our
young men In Harm's Way going door too
because we're a moral Army because we
don't want to kill
innocent mayor is it not as simple to
say that if Israel would just use Smart
bombs instead of dumb bombs that people
would be less against Israel I mean
she's she's just extraordinary this
woman she's just absolutely insane but
actually you were with me in Jerusalem
when I when I interviewed the deputy
mayor I think you introduced us actually
she was incredible she's an unbelievable
unbelievably effective Communicator for
Israel I mean she just reiterated
something that you said earlier actually
I think I think there's an interesting
misconception that people think that the
smarter they are the more complex they
get and the truth
is is simple the truth is simple it's
not complicated and Flur does it in the
most unbelievable way first of all you
know what if you could create a smart
bomb so to speak I think she should get
off her show try and invent one because
she'll become a millionaire if she can
do that probably a billionaire but it's
just a ridiculous it's just a ridiculous
notion to make and it just shows the
extent and the the the just unbelievable
again ignorance that comes to this
around this entire conflict what does
even whatever but I think that FL speaks
for the Jewish people for most of us and
for definitely for the Israelis this is
not complicated it is not a complicated
situation everyone's making it out to me
but it's not Kamas are responsible for
both Israel is responding morally to
every single situation it is put in to
an extent that we're sacrificing our own
people to ensure that there is no
innocent life left no one life is taken
for no reason our soldiers are dying in
Gaza instead of them just blitzing it
it's what I said before it's not that I
believe in the blitzing of Gaza
whatsoever but it's a possibility and it
wouldn't be a crazy response I think if
this in in the past paba Hiroshima right
this is It's there's a reality to the
fact that when somebody comes in and
says we want to kill as many people as
we possibly can the response to that is
to respond with strength and not to
respond with weakness and the fact that
we're being requested that time time
again is a joke and I think that going
simple uncomplicated reiterating the
same messages over and over again Hamas
is responsible we are trying to do the
right thing Kamas is responsible we are
trying to do the right thing there is no
other option come up with the better
solution you can't is the way to go
forward no justifications needed Amy uh
Andrea Mitchell I've been giving her a
hard time because she has been on the
wrong side of this for years and years
and years and she thinks I think
basically she knows she's a Jew and
she's on TV and she kind of thinks if
she's anti-israel that maybe she'll get
ahead it a few days later and that
actually might be right uh but here she
is once again taking a Hamas line and
trying to spin it and FL is not having
it that they have never had incidents of
their fuel being co-opted they deliver
it to people they know in the hospitals
these hospitals there were the amount of
fuel that Israel finally delivered to
alifa was enough for a half hour to an
hour of what is needed to generate their
equipment so you have babies dying taken
off of incubators first of all unra put
up a tweet at some point that their fuel
had been stolen by Hamas and then they
had to take it down because of course
they're very much intimidated these
International organizations and Hamas
operatives are very much embedded in
these organizations so everybody
whatever they're saying you also have to
take with the pinch of salt because
they're there and absolutely but
remember that Gaza even before October
7th had 4 hours of electricity a day why
because Hamas was sucking all the energy
out in order to keep going this Terror
infrastructure that they had under
underneath so the priority of Hamas has
never been its people and we're doing
everything we can we're sending
incubators we've sent fuel we'll
continue to send fuel we cannot
guarantee that fuel is not going to be
stolen by from us we were told by the
government that no no fuel is going in
we have images of fuel going in of
soldiers taking in fuel our soldiers um
are constantly in touch with the staff
of the hospital and we have even said
that it's not nearly enough but I let's
talk let's talk intimidation underneath
them is a whole Terror infrastructure
amyan I can't say the word that I want
to call her so I'm just going to write
it on my notes here just write write it
down a few times you'll you'll email it
to me I wrote it down I'm going to send
you this I'm going to sign it and send
it you'll have a Dave Rubin official
document um even at the end there even
at the end there give they are giving
fuel there is video evidence of it but
give fuel so their babies don't die
while they kill your babies look here
here's the thing okay all this
information coming from the government
the Hamas government of Gaza is giving
you this information so let me get this
straight uh a regime that's willing to
go into Israel Slaughter 1,400 people
Mass rape women kidnapped the elderly
behead babies they draw the line at
lying to the
Press like that's where they're that's
that's what they won't do like we we
have to presume that everything they
tell the Press is honest and accurate
the B the body counts the the the things
that are happening with fuel yeah let's
believe them on that because they would
never ever lie to the Press after what
they did on October 7th I mean it's
insane and just yeah the basic premise
of it all is to put that at the feet of
Israel uh to put that at the
accountability and the responsibility of
Israel to even have to be responsible
for that when Israel was the one
attacked to aay no account she should be
sitting there saying you know laying the
full responsibility of this entire
campaign at Hamas that committed an act
of unprecedented aggression against
Israel it's the worst crime since the
Holocaust against Israel and celebrated
it and that she's sitting down with
somebody and giving them guilt over the
suffering of the Palestinians that has
been brought on by this act of
aggression I mean like me said this is
not complicated and there are some
things so ridiculous only people in the
only an intellectual would say them
right I mean this idea of just this
moral confusion and this this desperate
need is sort of masochistic like it's
our fault it's our fault we have to you
know there there's this there's this
instinct to not want to blame the actual
people responsible for this so I want to
show you guys one more clip because for
years everyone has known in Israel and
outside of Israel that she hospital that
beneath it that's where Hamas
headquarters are that's where the
network of tunnel is that's likely where
the hostages are right now that's where
their command and Communication Center
is the whole freaking thing and of
course Andrew Mitchell earlier in the
week pretended that wasn't true either
uh here's the Pentagon admitting it
finally fully publicly we do have
information that Hamas and the
Palestinian Islamic Jihad uses some
hospitals in the Gaza Strip including
the alifa hospital um as a way to
conceal and support their military
operations and hold hostages they have
tunnels underneath these hospitals and
so Hamas and P members operate a command
and control node from alifa hospital in
Gaza City they have weapons stored there
and are prepared to respond to an
Israeli military operation against the
facility so this is I'm just telling you
what we as the um intelligence Community
assesses is happening in Gaza City how
Hamas is using these hospitals to
operate but absolutely we do not want to
see a firefight in a hospital where
there are innocent civilians Maya
there's a really bizarre moment there so
they admit something that basically
everybody has known and then she's like
oh and Hamas is ready to defend it like
really are you guys talking to Hamas
about what they're doing at that
hospital I mean I I don't think Hamas is
talking to anybody but I but I will say
this I think a big mistake that's being
made and it's it goes back on what I was
saying before
Hamas and the West talk different
languages to the West a hospital is
something that keeps people safe to
Hamas Theos hospital is something that
keeps them safe because they know that
they can use the West's sensitivity to
their own they mock us for this they
laugh at us for this they build 36
hospitals in Gaza and I don't know if
you've seen the size of Gaza but it's
not that big 36 hospitals for what it's
Hamas speak a language of terrorism and
it is not the same language that the
West speak they cook babies and if you
can't imagine that it's because you're
not speaking the language I think Israel
is doing a very good job and trying very
hard to act as an interpreter to deal
with Kamas on the level that they
deserve to be dealed with because this
is not a hospital this is an
infrastructure that has been created
under the pretense of a hospital and to
try and convey that in a way to the West
in a way that the West will understand
it but it's a
struggle Amy I give you the final word
today well I find it really
interesting just from a zoomed out
perspective how Obsessed the world is
with the intricate details of every
single step along the way that Israel
has to defend itself it does reveal this
certain hyper fixation on this addiction
Fe this fetish to cure scrutinize Israel
and only Israel uh in uh in defending
itself I mean there are so many causes
around the world and it just always rubs
me in the this very curious way of like
it's amazing
every military tactic that Israel's been
implementing to defend itself gets
scrutinized and you have to ask yourself
why why why the one Jewish state that
has to defend itself here um why does it
get subject to the scrutiny and then you
can have a discussion on what's
legitimate criticism and what's not but
just the to the extent that people are
hyper fixating on every detail of the
military campaign must beg the question
of this double standard of why Israel uh
gets this kind of attention um as
opposed to any other conflicts around
the world that don't get nearly as much
um it makes the case for you know
describing the uh you know the anti-
Zionism is certainly a mask for
anti-Semitism and I would just end on
the idea that the one silver lining in
all of this is that it's very hard to
fight evil when it's opusc when it's
hidden behind fancy slogans and things
like that but now what we are seeing in
the aftermath of October 7th is this
gleeful unap Unapologetic celebration of
hamas's actions of hamas's aims uh from
The River To The Sea uh you know uh
there is only one solution inata
Revolution to the extent that the masses
even understand what that means the
point is it's clear as day what the
motives are the genocide of Jews and the
destruction of the Jewish State the only
Jewish state in the world the only state
in the world that's not allowed to
defend itself is the Jewish one
apparently and this is clear as day
being being broadcast and and celebrated
and this is what these movements stand
for so it's easier to fight evil when
you can see it clearly and that's the
one one silver lining takeaway from all
of this if you had any Illusions about
what all of this was about it's here
right in front of us from your mouth to
Andrea Mitchell's ears uh before I let
you guys go uh Maya I just want to
personally thank you publicly because
not only were you you our tour guide in
Israel but you our friend you invited us
into your home and we met your family
and you shared your love of your country
with us and uh I think that's worth the
public thank you so thank you for that
my family is going to be very happy when
they see you said that
uh there's no postgame show I've got a
thing so we'll see you guys back here on
Monday
ciao